[Music]
[Music]
today we would like to present an
example of a joint effort in the field
of justice reform and modernization
at the heart of this project is an
effort to modernize the existing rules
of civil procedure which have undergone
a serious reformation for the first time
in 60 years
since 2016 the cypriot authorities
notably the supreme court of cyprus have
been implementing a significant and
complex reform of the court system
this process is supported by the
european commission and the council of
europe
[Music]
the severe backlog of cases in cypriot
courts
made it clear that something had to be
done
as the justice system was going to
collapse and could no longer meet the
needs of the economy and society
as a result the supreme court in a
report in 2016
codified the functional problems of the
courts and managed to secure technical
assistance from the european commission
for an overall judicial reform one of
the projects undertaken was the revision
of the civil procedure rules
this is one of the most complex and
technical projects that i was called to
manage
[Music]
the european commission through dg
reform the directorate general for
structural reforms provided technical
support assistance through various
projects to the cypriot authorities and
to the supreme court this was in the
context of this important and complex
judicial reform
the commission provided support in two
consecutive phases mobilizing different
group of experts to advise and assist
the supreme court in this endeavor we
had a very good result the main result
of this common and highly successful
effort is the modernization of the civil
procedure rules the cooperation
consisted of several elements
one reviewing the old cypriot civil
procedure rules
two supporting in carrying out public
consultations three providing technical
inputs for the preparation of the text
of the new rules and four and final
communicating on the new rules
according to the eu justice scoreboard
cyprus was repeatedly encouraged to
improve its performance in terms of
length of court proceedings and level of
backlogs in civil and commercial cases
the modernization of the civil procedure
rules should support this improvement
the eu justice scoreboard provides
comparable data on the independence
quality and efficiency of national
justice systems
it mainly focuses on civil commercial
and administrative cases
to pave the way for a more investment
business
and citizen friendly environment
[Music]
the new civil procedure rules constitute
a new modern approach to core
proceedings they provide for new code
management powers orientated on
efficiency and timely adjudication the
principle of overriding objective
constitutes the cornerstone in the new
civil process enabling the court to deal
with cases justly and a proportionate
cost this is an important development in
the work of domestic courts in line with
fair trial and rule of law standards
[Music]
this change
certainly represents a challenge
but we are ready and waited for these
changes that can lead to the upgrading
of our profession
we are looking forward to new
efficient and fast court proceedings
advocates will need to adapt to the
management of the procedure by judges
the new rules will also provide new
fields of work especially in mediation
and arbitration as a result of the need
to follow pre-action protocols and the
powers of the court to refer issues to
these adr mechanisms
[Music]
we are very happy to be able to
contribute to the judicial reform in
cyprus we do this with this project
a joint project of the council of europe
and the european union
which is successful
thanks to the commitment and the
dedication of the cypriot authorities
this project is also a very good example
of the cooperation and complementarity
of the european union and the council of
europe two organizations that are based
on the same values of protecting human
rights and the rule of law
the adoption of the new rules on
civil procedure in cyprus is a very
important step in the development of the
justice reform a reform which is
essential
for the mutual trust for the trust of
citizens to democratic institutions
and for the
economic growth of the country
today the european commission continues
cooperating with the cypriot authorities
and together with the council of europe
prepare the ground for implementation
through training activities for judges
lawyers and court registrars the
implementation of the new rules will
contribute to a fairer and more
efficient justice system for everyone
[Music]
you